The woman is a spiritual work and the child is
killed.I wonder if this person is also a person who has been modified by spiritual power.A modified
human.Which one should I kill first?
Mr. Kabo, I admit that I don't know anything.It
would be nice to have someone else with me on a trip with the three of us, and I'm also an
old man.  No, I'm just a farmer trying to avoid being attacked,
so I'll just spare my life. Are you an idiot? You're basically a monster, and you're calling a
farmer who doesn't know anything a monk. Don't
think about it. You're the one who took all the trouble to escape.  I'm trying to
do that, but it's enough. I'll
kill you. Don't kill me. Enough with the
play, idiot.
Get away from me. Or please help me. You're
going to get stronger. I've followed you this far, so there's no way I can
run away.  I can't go. I can't stay
weak even if I can go. It's okay.
At that time, at least
kill me so that I don't suffer.
[Music] Let's
do it.
[Music]
Yes.